if you google America's worst mom I'm
there for 68 Google pages
[Music]
it's gonna be for recent TV at Bleecker
Street Park here in New York City with
Lenore Eskenazi now
Lenore you've become famous for writing
columns now not only in the New York
Post you also had a book that came out
in 2009 free-range kids kids is the book
the blog the movement yep and it is a
movement when I talk to people about
that they're really inspired at the
thought of really I can stop worrying
and be a better parent um I don't know
if you'll be a better parent but you
don't have to worry to be a good parent
yeah and parenting nowadays is filled
with worry it is all about restriction
and regulation and hysteria when did you
first realize this um you know I
realized it before I became the
free-range mom I remember a friend
telling me that she had been at the at
Walmart or someplace like that and
waiting in line and the lady in line
behind her asked her if she would watch
the baby and my friend Melissa said yes
and then she told me wasn't that crazy I
mean I could have just stolen her baby
nobody should ever leave a child
unattended so she felt that the woman
behind her was crazy to trust her and
that's when I started thinking really
are we not supposed to trust our
children with anybody at any time and
that in fact is the mantra now you'll
find parents being arrested for letting
their kids play in the park really I get
these calls all the time letting their
kids play in the front yard the cops
come CPS comes and they say why are
these children unattended and they write
up the parents for negligence sometimes
the parents have to go to court so do
you think when we grew up we were
obviously less restricted I mean our mom
would say okay go out and play be back
by dinner why don't people do that
anymore
people don't do that anymore because
when my parents were raising me they
could not reel off the names Elizabeth
Smart and Jaycee Dugard and amber from
the Amber Alerts because the stories
hadn't become sensationalized local news
was still local and so because the media
loves those stories because they get the
biggest ratings those are the ones that
inhabit our brains and we start being
afraid once we're afraid then everything
tumbles from there then you start
getting you know neighbors who are
afraid because you think your kid is
safe in the front yard but they
your kid playing and they think that
mother doesn't care doesn't she realize
I had a woman write to my site who said
that she was on the lawn with her kids
but she was reading a book and a lady
came by and said put down that book
don't you realize your children could be
snatched at any minute
okay that's the kind of neighbor that
then calls the cops or CPS so if you're
living in a society like that where
everybody is turning into the KGB in
terms of your parenting it's very hard
to trust yourself trust your kids and
trust your community but I'm saying we
have to do you get a lot of backlash too
people say you're a bad parent because
of free-range kids because of this you
know really traditional style of
parenting but I feel like I am a really
traditional parent and yes I mean if you
if you google America's worst mom I'm
there for 68 Google pages so yes I've
gotten some backlash because people
really believe the worst case scenario
there's something I call worst first
thinking which is coming up with the
worst possible thing that could possibly
happen and proceeding as if it's likely
to happen you have to admit that there
is a little risk in everything and and
there has never been a safer time for
children on this planet than now and
that's not just me who says that that's
Steven Pinker at Harvard says we are in
the safest times ever in the history of
the world
my daughter's pediatrician had really
good advice she said a good adult will
never ask you for help they'll never ask
you to find a puppy they'll never ask
you to look for something or go off with
them that's excellent advice it's going
off that's the problem never get in a
car never go up it's so simple and also
it makes a lot more sense to kids
because when you tell kids don't talk to
strangers and then you go into your
store and you say I'd like a coffee what
are you doing you're talking to a
stranger and then if you're a polite
nice person you say excuse me when you
bump into somebody maybe you ask for
directions so yes you can talk to
strangers it's as simple as that
Lenore erskine AZ got a free range kids
comm read everything she's got
come out and like and liberated for
recent TV I'm Kennedy Thank You Lenore
oh thanks so much Kenny let's go play
[Music]